hey guys it is Tuesday my name is Josh
I'm Dan and you're watching games for
news here's what's going on if you're
like me you love two things surprises -
and Mario Plus rabbits Kingdom metal
well guess what what some surprise DLC
has been released for the latter with no
warning Ubisoft has released the ultra
challenge pack from Mari + rabbits
Kingdom battle the second dáil say after
the first steam punk and pixel inspired
weapons introduces 8 ultra hot
challenges there's no word on what these
entail but the trailer looks
appropriately controla Griffing ly
difficult any map that features birds
can get in the bin honestly there is
also a new co-op campaign that features
5 maps for you to test your friendships
with if you're interested in more
original minion turn-based blasting you
can grab the ultra challenge pack for 7
bucks or as part of the $20 season pass
if you were waiting for the next destiny
to exploit to crop up and be
subsequently dismantled it's finally
happened this one's great it's related
to a Monty Python silly walk one of
destiny toes many many emotes is a Monty
Python inspired high-kicking silly walk
the Bungie has since removed from sale
as it accidentally allowed players
access to some walled-off unfinished
areas as you can see here Bungie is yet
to offer up an official reason for its
removal but I think we can all figure
that out they clearly don't want you
back in Tessa's booth the emerge has
been available in bright and grand drops
since the game's release but it seems no
one noticed the bug until the emote went
on sale as an individual patches another
destiny to use the PC version of the
space shooting in luton game will
release next week on October 24th
there's a brand new trailer for the PC
version that you can check out right
here on games but finally has announced
their shuttering dead space developer
Visceral Games
most recently visceral was working on a
third-person story based Star Wars game
executive VP of EA worldwide studios
Patrick Sutherland said in a post on
EA's website throughout the development
process we have been testing the game
concept with players listening to the
feedback about what and how they want to
play and closely tracking fundamental
shifts in the marketplace it has become
clear that to deliver an experience the
players will want to come back to and
enjoy for a long time to come we need to
pivot the design oh dear the untitled
Star Wars game was headed up by ex
Naughty Dog and uncharted series
director Amy and
the game will now be developed by EA
Vancouver due to the moving of the bulk
of development to another studio EA will
be winding down and closing visceral
when reached by GameSpot for comment EA
confirmed that Hennig is no longer
involved in the project and that the
studio is quote in discussions with Amy
about her next move in the statement
subtle and also said that EA is in the
midst of shifting as many of the team as
possible to other projects and teams at
EA that's everything we have for you
today make sure you tune in tomorrow for
our last episode this week because we're
not going to be here Thursday and Friday
you're gonna have two very special guest
hosts but yeah then this is a wind-up
part now where I've finished off my
sentence we'll see anything I make